so here we are and it's getting steeper
you can only drive down it and then only
just
welcome to the steepest street in Wales
test one my nephew's skateboard test -
they do say that house bricks actually
roll down here not rolling but it's
going its name this is fourth
penslar Gwynn and his team have been
taking measurements all week and have
now sent them off to try and claim the
world record there are criteria that you
have to fit into the house that the
street has to have houses it has to be a
public thoroughfare in other words
people can drive along it and it has to
be paved open survey indicate that it's
the gradient is greater than that on in
Dunedin well yes but obviously all this
needs verification for years the good
people of Baldwin Street in Dunedin New
Zealand have considered there's the
steepest this challenge from Wales has
rattled the mayor of Dunedin if the well
streets which might have superb it's not
so stupid but if it turns out to be a
super being we will call on the gods of
earthquake and tilt our street a little
more title the setting here is majestic
just beneath hala castle the idea of
claiming the world record for their
narrow lane is already pulling more
visitors the Kiwis can say what they
want but the measurements will speak the
truth whatever happens we're this has
been brilliant for harloff and we're
really proud of our little lane the walk
is pretty tough hiking it is possible
and so is running it whatever tricks the
New Zealanders want to pull the people
of Harlech are confident they've got
this Tom Parmenter Sky News Northwest
Wales